okay so you guys already couple of hours
into the game okay the big bad guy Rhys
asked you to help them out in order for
a certain favor okay
so our job will be to restore the
communications in the area but since
we're playing co-op we're going to goof
around a little bit
Timo's going to lead the waves go
anyone's going to lead the way so come
on where are you yeah
oh there Yas disco yeah and he has
tackling t-shirt alright so we started
at night oh my god that's the suicide
I'm not sure that was a good idea so be
careful look at the vision cons
qualifier yeah you see when you take a
look at the mini-map there our vision
calls you start to volatile these are
the night creatures and when they see
you they basically want to get in try to
kill you yeah you gotta keep moving go
don't try to kill him just just run away
alright survive okay this is a fresh
start you why are you not dead you
should go for the head way that that was
the arm that's good because there's
never very good about there you go there
you go head arm OS I love Apple me it's
like I said getting to an objective as a
group is kind of difficult direction
yeah there's so many distractions go to
the overpass yeah you see those you see
those scars on the overpass yeah yeah oh
yeah get on top of it so we're just
gonna contact our base and tell them
that we're ready to take that mission
all right nice two out of four already
there alright people oh well there we're
not actually gonna save it it seems like
we're gonna kill him but oh these are
the bad guys no no they live saving them
no here we go and take their weapons
what having them from life oh yeah
that's a good thing
tyonne we're killing the guys at home
zombies we are now what oh yeah
who's draw the electric weapon hey where
did you get that I think with me oh
really oh nice good job mainly seems to
rise all right grab their stuff check
your pockets
oh and there's a guy oh look we actually
actually did say the guy oh we did save
him and that's beautiful
headshot that man you're safe ya know
check check him out choke these dude out
he's probably gonna give you a nice
reward oh there you go you got it Maude
you brought him on now come on okay so
go to the inventory okay um it was
Sasson what does it do oh it improves
your handling so that means your weapons
gonna cost less time enough to you ain't
gonna be able to swing more before you
get exhausted cool summit my pick is now
even faster what are you doing see okay
so you got to be careful because even
though you guys playing co-op we like to
spice things up a moment so every once
in a while the game will suggest a
competition like who can kill more
zombies or the one that was there but
you didn't took it you can find more
loot in like a minute it's on top of the
building I'm searching oh yeah four
varnas like it alright yeah you can
never have enough loot you can never
have enough loot all right it's on the
top of that building so you have to find
a way
don't touch my sweet parkour right now I
felt it a whole sorry there's a whole
little bit of yeah oh there's all bees
are coming door hello right behind you
right behind you a lot of people might
participate
yeah I mean so we're not only gonna say
unlocking the safe house but whoever
kills more zombies gonna win some extra
all right oh here we go here we go you
guys ready all right go for it Mars on V
yeah
get off the edge kick him kick him in
the ass yeah oh yeah
Oh get off the edge off the edge it's
not used in my own video you're not oh I
took a zipline kill reasons not gonna
win the kayak nearly zip-lined my way
across town Wow
I really showed that zombie he was boss
alright who's winning is he winning
oh man I wish it was a reverse zipline
he was on B's this way
on the plus side I can see you guys
running around and you're doing great
you're looking great oh he's dropping
too bad you missed it oh you know that
was actually the vault because yeah you
jump you owe some B's yeah exactly
if you ever need to read some safe place
on top of something just you can
actually jump for money pull up your old
friends yes oh just revolvers good
thanks thanks remember to loot that's
gonna save you this gonna give you more
health okay oh you're gonna love this
one
this is how much drove through Mellie
yeah this is drunk yeah all right here
we go
Oh beautiful slow-mo as well
utilize you can pick him back yes
absolutely don't drive over baseball you
Oh surprise
Jennifer's made to hit kill you but I
did well now they're definitely gonna
try to kill me oh oh no oh what a
terrible man I got next
what um she's like we need some help
guys guys goes up in a bit of a fight
she had to scream it over something it
was honourable I swear yeah oh yeah in
the meantime there's an airdrop comes on
their job yeah that's the Lutheran it's
goats commune here drop now I don't know
if you noticed but it's really hard to
get to the objective when you're playing
co-op this is just somewhat stuff going
on maybe their trip will give us
something we can kill the guy
oh you get there okay oh yeah the drops
all right you got the drops so if you
can deliver them to quartermaster you're
gonna get a lot of XP my habit is
nothing does nothing baseball that it
feels so much like shorter than ow crap
maybe you could drop kicking oh geez
science is off him drop kick oh I don't
know if I got it I kicked him yeah
remember Duncan dodge you're like hyena
say money that guy was rich can we set
him on fire
uh well they have like a Molotov or
something
what do I have count like a book reports
I just do something yeah check your in
check your energy firecrackers guys know
sort of my work nothing or how sort of
right at hitting on the gas tank it a
little gas tank yeah now step away step
away Oh run all right oh you turned off
watch it flew away read miss you oh hey
you guys doing with this guy the Dead
Yet
hold on Harrison heart smash oh all
right somebody's dad who's dead
okay nice get his rebar candy all right
you're gonna show to the face pound I
know
oh he's coming for me huh whoo yeah I
was your survivor say well offended big
dude is he's warming up oh whoa was that
was that once blew up music he just
smashed one of the earth it killed
everyone except me I think all right
listen
put some firecrackers well you could
actually try to learn him over here and
send it on fire with your fire front
that night oh is that already good okay
whoops she's in a rush to get to me oh
that that is a row nice then you caught
up the head beautiful can you kick it
yes I can there we go
so that's tow yeah he does that that
see you agree news the reason why Nome
is dead now I think he's dead guys and
he just threw like five three three not
all waste of resources
yeah it seems pretty there yeah he seems
pretty dose oh he's also horribly on
fire which means I can't get to his
buddy and you want to loot it ah
no yeah oh so heal me quick kill me what
is our for loot kill me ladders seems a
bit easy
yeah alright who's who's first maybe
stop panicking and look around no never
ever make like that yeah you can collect
no we can climb oh all right so camera's
not taking not participating you just
die well my fingers what last words were
I can't climb that evidently no oh you
can use survivor sense just press and
hold a and you'll be able to find the
other guys yeah there they are
I got it is having a great time just
throwing shovels of people there you go
yeah he did yes yeah well you kill him
another one bites the dust oh yeah
you're all right okay so my school for
the season yeah my favorite child oh by
the way there's a net kid and yeah I
alluded oh and there's another one razor
blades in a medkit oh no no that's not a
bag that's a chance that Kitty's on the
wall you never run
Oh God you're fast
yeah that's viral oh not me you jerk
Oh big all right for that yeah I know
finish it yeah mark universe yes
all right we finally in we're finally I
what's cool stuffing we have a gun
oh there you go oh just one one thing
you need to know how I got a gun
the guns are pretty loud they're very
powerful but they're loud so so you're
gonna attract good thing right yeah he's
running yeah and you run away away for
you but a travel oh wow ah he was Tommy
thanks you know he actually gets points
every time he's driving you try why is
he killing me
I think he's doing it on the purpose and
you in my travels are careful Oh still
Oh No there you go flying pretty fast
nice yeah one more look at her again
only gonna pull over again that ladder I
chem this is your challenge what time to
shine
yeah oh wait no yes that was closed off
so let's go to that bar yep nice
yes bars yes perfect thank you grab that
oh yeah just go right for it
fine climb out Oh three or three - no no
I felt oh damn it really all right good
good good good good
don't fold out don't fill up yeah hey I
won now don't fall don't fall you still
have to sweat flip the switch have you
done it worthy yep okay I'm gonna go up
there sir okay you guys you guys got
this doing tonight oh just give me fun
oh yeah your bite oh yeah
I felt that well yeah as a biggest
Persian hmm
ah this didn't go to plan at all max yes
max to the the neck good it's gonna get
dark really soon
oh you can pick those up oh yeah oh yeah
I'll throw it Oh Ethan
Oh what that's crazy boom
Yass company that I can [ __ ] he stops
the head well then how far away is this
guy um you see the two towers in the
horizon like the two big to big
buildings that's him
so we should be quiet right uh yeah we
hope but the good thing is we gonna we
gonna give stuff to quartermaster and
there's also shop so we're gonna buy
some powerful weapons to survive tonight
so let's head to the shop let's sell all
the crap that we have and let's buy some
really awesome weapon lose your sense
use your sense look he's there he's over
there yeah what's up without oh I see
yeah he sees you he sees you get away
from here haha I remember that he have a
UV flashlight on your left trigger if
you if you ever need to scare it it
volatile away oh oh now scary is it
possible to kill the volatiles yes but
they're pretty tough climb I'm like you
mean it
hey hey oh the safest just here yeah
just make it run and jump for it yeah
hello I really hurt I made it oh god
yeah Oh some firecrackers like turn with
a frankerz dude right there yeah there
you go that was a throwing star oh okay
yeah whoops oh I think they noticed Lucy
I think they notice Lucy and they're
looking for her right now
Oh No jump oh wait you can't - you see
me alright quick run away around it go
40 objective and there's a safe house
set the objective
alright all bets are off alright yeah
are you gonna level up nice nice up nice
up man are we safe here no um at least
three of you because somebody's left
outside is that okay you can do it you
can do it come on come on
look at look at them chasing it ah they
got a cube oh nice